bonjour donc petit point d'agenda en
cette semaine de vacances scolaires
donc nous aurons partir jeudi 22 octobre
à 15 heures la participation de nicolas
sarkozy au congrès du parti populaire
européen donc congrès qui a lieu au
palais municipal des congrès à madrid
on va faire un commentaire sur la
prestation du président de la république
sur rtl ce matin
après donc seulement un mois après à la
conférence présidentielle françois
hollande entretient toujours la
confusion et l'ambiguïté il a fait un
one man show
le one man show d'un homme seul devant
son miroir malgré cette heure d'antenne
il n'est pas parvenu à calmer les
inquiétudes des français que ce soit sur
le chômage la croissance la crise des
migrants les impôts la sécurité avec les
chiffres de la délinquance qui sont
toujours en augmentation malgré quand
même cette petite ce petit arrangement
est tout de même sorti les chiffres des
viols des chiffres de la délinquance et
sans que cela n'émeuve personne donc
finalement c'est un président qui n'a
pas été très convaincant sans vision
claire sans leadership comme à son
habitude dans l'autosatisfaction le
nombrilisme
il a fait de l'incantation voilà donc
sur les deux engagements phares de la
campagne de françois hollande qui sont
le chômage et la jeunesse on assiste
finalement à deux échecs majeurs
il n'a absolument rien proposé là dessus
les mesures du rapport cambre excellent
qui devrait faire l'objet de discussions
approfondies d'une table ronde pendant
cette conférence sociale ont tout
simplement été enterré pas un seul mot
sur le temps de travail pas un seul mot
sur la réforme du contrat de travail ni
sur la réforme du code du travail
il a enterré ses sujets au profit de
sujet plus consensuel sans impact sur la
relance
l'économie ni sur le marché du travail
donc ils vont évoquer la coop 21 la
transformation numérique du travail le
compte personnel d'activité on aurait
aimé avoir un françois hollande qui qui
fasse preuve de courage et qui évoque
les propositions et à mesure qu'ils
avaient dans le rapport qu'ont rexel
mais le courage n'est pas véritablement
ce qui caractérise françois hollande
alors il a évoqué le cas le drian le
ministre de la défense qui est également
maintenant candidat aux régionales et
nous avons pu noter quand même deux
poids deux mesures puisque et ca sera la
jurisprudence le drian le drian au
ministre peut être candidat aux
régionales tout en gardant son poste de
ministre de la défense
carole delga femmes ministres avaient
pour obligation de démissionner quitter
son poste au gouvernement pour pouvoir
être candidate dans la région midi
pyrénées face à dominique rennais donc
ce deux poids deux mesures est
complètement scandaleux où sont les
féministes de gauche
le drian aujourd'hui doit véritablement
choisir on ne peut pas avoir un ministre
de la défense à mi-temps à un moment où
la france est engagée à l'international
notamment face à des ch et les bretons
qui connaissent d'énormes difficultés la
bretagne qui connaît une crise assez
importante ne peut pas se satisfaire non
plus d'un candidat et d'un et d'un
président de région qui sont en
présidant un candidat peut-être
président à un mi-temps donc le drian
doit doit clarifier sa situation et nous
demandons à françois hollande qu'il n'y
ait pas de deux poids deux mesures quand
quand il s'agit d'un homme ou d'une
femme candidat à la présidence d'une
région l'autre fourberie de hollande le
tartuffe c'est qu'il n'est pas
responsable d'après lui de
l'augmentation des impôts locaux
de qui se moque-t-il c'est quand même
lui qui a baissé la dotation aux
collectivités locales de 12 milliards
qui les asphyxier qu'ils les eaux
luge en transférant des charges a
augmenté les impôts au niveau local je
pense que les français ne sont pas dupes
et la mobilisation de l'association des
maires de france menée par françois
baroin l'a bien démontré un autre point
dans cette longue interview était sur le
référendum dans les entreprises nous
considérons que le dernier mot doit être
laissée aux entreprises et aux salariés
c'est à eux de décider via une
consultation un référendum au sein de
l'entreprise et cela monsieur hollande
semble le refuser il a également évoqué
l' immobilier voulait prendre des
décisions mais la seule véritable
décision qu'il doit prendre ses selles
d'abroger purement et simplement la loi
allure appelée également la loi du flou
donc finalement 7 7 7
cette interview n'a été qu'un pare-feu
pour cacher l'échec du référendum de ce
week end de monsieur cambadélis est
également c'est finalement aussi quelque
part panique à l'elysée on les sondages
montrent france hollande qui décroche
toujours plus dans les sondages il a
perdu trois points et donc il s'est
décidé hier à venir sur le plateau de
rtl pour pouvoir parler aux français
mais les français ne l'entend plus les
français ne le voit plus alors pour
revenir sur le référendum de la
consultation de monsieur cambadélis ce
week-end on a envie de lui dire bon bah
très bien maintenant place à la
transparence
place à la démocratie il ya eu seulement
68 représentants dans les départements
pour 2500 bureaux de vote où est la
haute autorité du parti socialiste
d'ailleurs on peut noter que emmanuelle
cosse et edwy plenel ont également voté
sans le savoir certains journalistes ont
voté plus d'une dizaine de fois chez les
républicains
lorsque nous consultons nos adhérents il
ya eu six qui vient et qui certifie qui
certifie
vote et la bonne démarche de cette
consultation en attend autant de
transparence de la part du parti
socialiste y compris sur le nombre
d'adhérents
voilà monsieur cambadélis fait venir les
ligier au parti socialiste fait preuve
de transparence
et puis au delà de cette démarche c'est
surtout le signe d'une gauche qui est
totalement en miettes et et qui ne
parvient pas à se rassembler ni avoir
une ligne convaincante pour pour
permettre l'unité de leur camp donc
comme le disait lydien cette conférence
de presse plus tôt cette intervention à
la radio de françois hollande est là
pour masquer l'échec du référendum
socialistes mais aussi masquer l'échec
de la conférence sociale qui a lieu
aujourd'hui ou d'abord la cgt un des
principaux syndicats est absente
et puis où les thèmes qui sont abordés
sont en réalité des thèmes qui sont sans
grand enjeu pour jaillir la mère des
batailles c'est à dire la guerre contre
le chômage pour finalement créer de
l'emploi dans notre pays
d'ailleurs les français ne s'y trompent
pas un sondage démontre que 59% des
français trouvent cette conférence
sociale pas utile et lorsqu'on regarde
les thèmes la cap 21 le compte personnel
d'activité ou la transformation
numérique du travail on s'aperçoit que
il n'y a pas de grands enjeux à cette
conférence sociale
en tout cas sur le sur le champ de
l'emploi
nous chez les républicains nous avons
fait un certain nombre de propositions
pour réformer le code du travail et
monsieur hollande a essayé de
caricaturer notre nos propositions et
notamment celle du référendum
d'entreprise
bien évidemment je rappelle à monsieur
hollande qui a pas dû lire toutes les
lignes que le référendum d'entreprise
n'aurait lieu qu'à partir du moment où
il ya un blocage dans la négociation
entre les partenaires sociaux
et puis nous avons vu un françois
hollande qui a utile
lisez à longues heures d'intervention
des formules creuses la france apaisée
la france va mieux alors il ya peut-être
que lui qui voit que la france va mieux
puisque on voit que deux mois en mois
nous battons des records de chômage le
les déficits galope et on est dans une
crise de l'immobilier sans précédent
donc je pense que le bon docteur
hollande n'a pas bien fait le diagnostic
du patient france et puis la france est
robuste et bien heureusement qu'elle est
robuste parce que si elle ne l'était pas
avec le ce que lui inflige françois
hollande et bien il serait complètement
moribonde
donc françois hollande nous parle d'une
france apaisée
alors si nous regardons ces dernières
semaines que la france est loin d'être
apaisé la semaine dernière une
manifestation de 7000 policiers devant
la chancellerie
ça ne s'était pas vu depuis 2001 et
avant depuis 1983
parce que françois hollande depuis qu'il
est président de la république s'est
abstenu de recevoir à l'elysée les
syndicats des policiers même alors qu'au
début de l'année avec la tentative d'eau
et avait eu trois morts chez les
policiers
et bien pas c'était pas nécessaire de
les recevoir de ce compte de leur côté
les médecins également son temps en
mouvement j'allais dire depuis de
nombreuses semaines
ils n'ont également jamais été reçu par
françois hollande
l'impression que pour être reçu par
françois hollande il faut être soit
membre du parti socialiste soit
frondeurs soit être un écolo en colère
mais en tout cas
souvenez-vous pendant la campagne
présidentielle de moi je président
disait qu'il ne recevrait pas les
parlementaires de la majorité ce qui
s'est avéré être un mensonge
mais il avait oublié d'y oublier de dire
qu' il ne recevrait pas à l'elysée les
représentants syndicaux des médecins des
représentants syndicaux des policiers
alors finalement suite à cette
manifestation de 7000 policiers en
colère il a décidé de changer son fusil
d'épaulé que normalement cette semaine
ils seront reçus mais il faut vraiment
être en crise pour que monsieur hollande
daigne recevoir enfin les syndicats de
policiers et puis nous avons les
enseignants qui sont fous furieux avec
la réforme du collège et ensuite nous
avons dans une des plus grandes
entreprises françaises
air france est bien des violences et
c'est donc tout cela que monsieur
hollande appelle la france apaisée je
pense que monsieur hollande devrait
revoir son vocabulaire
alors dans cet univers un peu sombre on
a quelques éclaircies et nous avons vu
avec satisfaction qu'un accord s'était
conclue avec la régir et l'arrco sur les
retraites complémentaires c'est une
belle avancée
nous nous en réjouissons ça démontre que
la méthode qui avait été utilisé
par nicolas sarkozy avec la réforme des
retraites de 2010 est la bonne il faut
adapter l'âge de départ à la retraite à
l'évolution de l'espérance de vie de nos
concitoyens
et c'est d'ailleurs cette réforme des
retraites de 2010 qui permet que l'
équilibre sur le régime général sera
atteint l'année prochaine on a un
françois hollande qui ce matin s'est
gargarisé sur le fait que les retraites
été pérennisé jusqu'en 2030 ce qu'il a
oublié de dire c'est que cette éclaircie
eh bien elle est due à la réforme de
2010 et donc il y a un grand principe
c'est que la réforme les réformes des
retraites ne peuvent pas être figé il
devra régulièrement appelé de nouvelles
est rappelé par don de nouvelles de
nouvelles réformes pour s'adapter à
l'évolution de l'espérance de vie
c'est une impérieuse nécessité pour
sauver notre site